étonnante proposition de vietti cure
propose à l'onu de retirer toutes ses
troupes hors de ses frontières
hommages du monde entier andrei sakharov
le physicien et morts à 68 ans d'une
crise cardiaque
un symbole de l'opposition bob denard
suite et fall mercenaires a quitté les
comores avec ses compagnons il a cédé à
l'armée française chili la victoire
delwyn au premier tour mais les
difficultés commencent former une
majorité est contre et hino chez
toujours chef de l'armée bonsoir
c'était à l'onu cet après midi le vice
ministre soviétique des affaires
étrangères annoncé qu lurs s'apprêtait à
retirer ses troupes tout ses troupes
hors de ses frontières
dans les démocraties populaires et
ailleurs ce sont donc six cent soixante
dix mille hommes qui pourraient rentrer
au pays
en fait il semble bien que gorbatchev
préfère prendre les devants d'une part
pour faire des économies sur le plan
intérieur et ensuite parce qu'il craint
des incidents dans les pays de l'est qui
se sont démocratisés récemment regardez
par exemple ce reportage à postdam
c'est une ville de garnison soviétique
en allemagne de l'est la population
n'apprécie pas jérôme boni roger motte
potsdam
les soldats soviétiques potsdam et leur
plus grande ville de garnison en
allemagne delhaize 58 ans environ depuis
45 ans il occupe avec leurs familles des
quartiers entiers de la ville
les livres d'histoire de l'art dial sont
plaints de l'amitié entre les peuples
allemand et soviétique
les chars libérateur de 45 sont érigés
en monuments et les enfants de la ville
connaissent bien leurs leçons
s'il n'était pas l'engouement comment
vivrait sous l'occupation fasciste
si cette alerte il y a dans les
garnisons soviétique il ne nous a pas
souri aux yeux à potsdam
malgré les événements la cohabitation
semble se poursuivre tant bien que mal
sont un peu encombrant ils sont très
rationnel résultats dans mon jardin par
exemple il récolte les pommes avant
pour l'instant les forces soviétiques à
potsdam s'en tienne à de strictes
consignes de non ingérence
même quand les manifestants se sont
emparés de l'immeuble de la police
secrète est-allemande le commandement
soviétique
juste à côté n'a pas bronché dans la
population les avis sont partagés sur le
principe même de cette présence
soviétique
à mon avis personnel ce ne sont pas eux
qui me dérange le plus nous laissent
tranquilles ils vivent modestement
parfois on a presque pitié de leur mode
de vie les temps qu'ils rentrent
normalement ils doivent rester encore
quelques années mais dans les
circonstances actuelles on n'a plus
besoin du nom pour le moment 1 a
tellement de choses à réaliser dans
notre pays
la présence soviétique avait cadet de
nos soucis mais le grand frère
laissera-t-il les allemands de l'est
régler leurs problèmes de même toute la
question est là
alors justement revenons sur cette
proposition soviétique de ramener tous
ces soldats à l'intérieur de ses propres
frontières avec nous alexandre adler la
spécialiste des questions soviétique à
libération notamment
alors à quoi correspond à votre avis
cette nouvelle proposition soviétique
ben je crois à la fois à une prise en
compte de la réalité nouvelle qui vient
de faire irruption partout maintenant il
ya des gouvernements qui vont être
librement élu tous souhaitent voir les
soldats soviétiques partir alors c'est
un peu reprend une balle de volée est en
est qu'il va falloir partir et bien l
union soviétique prend les devants et
dit bah oui nous partons mais tout ça
doit se négocier alors ça évite de
courir l'europe et rapport en
particulier les tchèques qui n'avaient
pas de troupes soviétiques avant 68 ils
vont maintenant demander le nouveau
ministre des affaires étrangères
energiedienst bir lahfay que les
soviétiques c'en est assez vite ils
peuvent dire oui mais nous devons
négocier sa mule de façon multilatérale
il
ils enlèvent disons un élément grave de
tension en europe centrale en déclarant
cela et se donne un peu le temps d'agir
alors en fait ils prennent les devants
alors ça c'est pour les démocraties
populaires mais l'armée rouge est
présente dans bien d'autres pays
c'est à dire par exemple cuba le vietnam
alors là alors là c'est peut-être là où
ce sera le plus sérieux et le plus
spectaculaire parce que finalement en
europe centrale on voit bien que le
principe est acquis mais qu' il y aura
un certain délai à négocier que les
états unis en particulier tandis que
dans le cas des ces accords qui sont
tous bilatéraux les choses peuvent aller
beaucoup plus vite et quand on voit les
invitations que fidel castro manifeste à
l'égard des soviétiques peut-être at-il
su voici déjà quelques jours que la
brigade soviétique les forces navales
qui étaient là qui est une sorte de
garantie pour la sécurité de cuba allait
être retirée en ce qui concerne le
vietnam la grande base de cam ranh aussi
est un très sérieux problème
on voit que les soviétiques ont visité
les chinois ça pourrait être la mort
d'une grande détente dans toute cette
région c'est peut-être le plus
spectaculaire à venir et finalement à
votre avis c'est une proposition
réellement importante
oui alors on vit une telle époque avec
de tels événements que finalement on a
l'impression que tout ça fait partie
maintenant d'une sorte de routine parce
que après leur chute du mur qu est ce
qui peut nous étonner mais en temps
normal ça ferait quand même la une des
journaux ce n'est tout de même pas
courant de voir un pays annoncée à tel
retrait même si on sait bien que tout ça
ne se fera pas du jour longue
merci alexandre adler les autres sectes
d'andrei sakharov auront lieu lundi
sakharov était la conscience de l'union
soviétique comme le désigner ses amis il
est mort d'une crise cardiaque hier soir
à moscou fils aura lutté jusqu'au bout
pour ses idéaux de démocratie et
d'humanisme le savant prix nobel de la
paix qui était aussi le père de la bombe
atomique soviétique avait été élu au
congrès des députés après de longues
années d'exil
corinne pertuis à moscou émotion je suis
un peu fatigué je vais aller me reposer
ce sont les dernières paroles d'andreï
sakharov hier après une journée
épuisante des discussions agitées au
parlement
l'académicien député du peuple s'est
allongée qu'on ne plus se réveiller
il est mort probablement d'une crise
cardiaque
ce matin dès l'annoncé officielle de sa
mort une foule de moscovites s'est rendu
à son domicile pour lui rendre un
dernier hommage
et si vous êtes
c'est le meilleur homme du pays qui est
mort il était la conscience d'autres
pays mais pas seulement de notre pays et
notre peuple aussi il se préoccuper de
tout le monde mais plus petit au plus
grand et du plus lointain ou plus proche
c'est le malheur de notre pays de
n'avoir pas su comprendre un homme comme
sakharov intelligent il n'a été compris
ni par le gouvernement ni par le peuple
c'est un grand malheur maintenant
j'espère qu'un mais pas seulement 1 des
millions de sa carence vont surgir qu'il
y ait des hommes comme ça la vie va
changer sinon on n'arrivera à rien
les réactions michael gorbatchev a dit
par exemple qu'il ressentait
profondément cette grande perte ce sont
ses mots
d'autres réactions pour le président
mitterrand andreï sakharov était un
pionnier des droits de l'homme
pour george bush le président américain
sakharov personnifié tout ce qui est bon
et honnête de l'homme je vous propose
maintenant de revenir sur la vie et les
combats d'andrei sakharov qu'il avait
d'abord connu tous les honneurs
mais le régime communiste l'avait peu à
peu rejetées jusqu'à l'exil et pendant
six ans à gorki la paire être la
pérestroïka de mikhaël gorbatchev lui a
permis de revenir défendre au grand jour
ses vidéos d'humanisme jacques merino
portrait il aurait pu vivre comme un
privilégié et avoir accès à toutes les
facilités accordées à la nomenclature à
mais ils n'en voulaient pas andrei
sakharov que l'on voit ici reçu à dîner
il y a un an à l'elysée fut en effet
pendant longtemps très à l'honneur à
moscou pour avoir fortement contribué à
la mise au point de la bombe h
soviétique il fut trois fois désigné
héros de l'urss couvert d'éloges et de
décoration cet homme frêle aux épaules
voûtées à la voie à chevrotante ne
renonça jamais sa liberté de penser et
c'est par ce mot
définissez vous vous sentez toujours par
l'esprit dissidents il ya c'est à sydney
j'ai toujours défendu des positions
constructives
je suis un dissident en ce sens que je
dis ce que je pense sans craindre les
conséquences possibles qui pourraient en
résulter de même que mes amis qui ont ce
faire beaucoup plus que moi cette
liberté d'esprit pourtant lui avait
coûté cher le 22 janvier 1981 il est
arrêté sur ordre de brejnev ses prix et
ses décorations lui sont retirés et sans
autre forme de procès il est exilé à
gorki à 400 km de moscou
il n'a plus le droit de communiquer et
la ville est interdite à tous les
étrangers de lui on obtient alors que
quelques images volées exil humiliation
vexations de tous ordres ils payent le
prix d'un combat commencé dans les
années 60 lorsque avec sa femme elena
bonner il créa le comité de défense des
droits de l'homme son exil du aura cette
année
réhabilité par mikhaïl gorbatchev il
voit en juin dernier son combat couronné
par son élection au soviet suprême
chaud partisan de la perestroïka et de
lagaf' menace il ne ménage pas pour
autant ses critiques envers grand bal
shirt il y a quelques jours à la tribune
du congrès et s'accrochaient vivement
avec lui sur la question du monopole du
parti communiste andré soucarrat devait
reprendre la parole aujourd'hui il est
mort hier soir en préparant son
intervention jusqu'à la dernière minute
cet homme se sera battue pour plus de
liberté et de démocratie
verdict sévère à la cour d'assises
spéciale de paris pour le terroriste
habib ammar le tunisien qui était accusé
notamment de l'attentât de marks &
spencer en 85 à paris a été condamné à
perpétuité avec une peine de 18 ans de
sûreté
les jurys les jurés pardon ne lui ont
pas accordé de circonstances atténuantes
dominique verdeilhan
il a fallu moins d'une heure et demie
pour juger un terroriste et une balance
une femme courageuse exemplaire qui a
refusé de porter la mort c'est le
portrait qu'a brossé de souad aïssaoui m
lagrange son avocat mais que
vouliez-vous qu'elle fit face à bill
maamar elle était dans les mains d'un
poseur de bombe
combien y at il eu de personnes qui ont
dénoncé les terroristes une sole et vous
n'avez même plus de jurés populaires
pour les juger devant une cour d'assises
et mettre la grange de conclure que si
soual aïssaoui était condamné la cour
est les dissuader d'autres personnes à
faire de semblable révélations un
sentiment partagé par l'avocat général
un avocat général plus sévères vis-à-vis
d'habib mama en qui ils ne voient qu'un
robot conditionné m arapian son avocat
n'a pu que revenir sur la défense
présentée hier par son client il a fait
de son mieux pour qu'il y ait le moins
de victimes possible mais ce ne fut sans
doute pas suffisant pour accorder habib
ammar les circonstances atténuantes
ce soir comme après trois jours de
procès tout sépare les exams en abyme
ammar a été condamné à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
souad aïssaoui elle a été acquittée bob
dénard a capitulé aux comores devant la
pression de l'armée française le
mercenaire et 21 de ses compagnes ont
quitté les îles pour johannesburg en
afrique du sud l'accueil qui leur a été
réservé était paraît-il glacial l'armée
française peut maintenant cesser ces
manoeuvres au large des comores laurent
boussier marine a quitté les comores
comment ça va se passer pour lui
maintenant comment ça va se passer pour
vous en france est-ce que vous avez un
point de chute
flash bousculades et rafale de questions
pour les pouces comorienne de bob dénard
et les quatre officiers mercenaires qui
ont débarqué ce matin à roissy après
avoir quitté hier soir moroni aux
comores monde et six mois tu as l'air
visiblement les consignes étaient
strictes déclaration à la presse réduite
au minimum et mises à l'abri immédiat
par des hommes à poigne qui n'ont pas
laissé passer les journalistes quelques
heures avant sur l'aéroport de la
capitale comorienne
une courte cérémonie qui avait bel et
bien été une passation officieuse de
pouvoir avait eu lieu
cinquante parachutistes français arrivés
à bord de cinq hélicoptères puma avait
pris la relève des mercenaires à la tête
de la garde présidentielle
une cérémonie suivie du départ de bob
dénard et de 25 de ses hommes à bord
d'un avion hercules pour l'afrique du
sud ce soir laventure comorienne de bob
dénard est terminée il est arrivé il y à
une heure à pretoria et ce sont des
parachutistes français crient à la
demande des autorités comoriennes assure
le maintien de l'ordre à moroni le
gouvernement engage sa responsabilité
sur la loi de programmation militaire
le budget de l'armée le gouvernement
ainsi recours à l'article 49 3 qui
permet l'adoption de la loi sans vote
sauf bien sûr en cas de motion de
censure grincements au parti communiste
depuis trois jours le comité central et
réunis place du colonel fabien
la discussion la plus attendue était
celle d'aujourd'hui puisque les
communistes parler des pays de l'est
alors nous ne savions pas tout sur ces
pays a dit maxime gré met par exemple
pour excuser l'attitude du parti
communiste français ces dernières années
bref au pc plus ça bouge à l'est moins
ça change
chez les communistes français véronique
saint-yves georges marchais absents
charles fiterman absents henri krasucki
absents pourtant le comité central du
parti communiste s'est déroulé comme
d'habitude il est des murs qui ne tombe
pas comme d'habitude les amis des
rénovateurs reconstructeurs et autres
refondateurs ont essayé de se faire
entendre mais on les a pas écoutés
comme d'habitude la direction a
réaffirmé ses principes intangibles dans
tous les domaines
l'autocritique n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour au parti communiste français
les communistes élise définisse son
coauteur de la de la politique de leur
parti
personne n'est propriétaire du parti
communiste ce sont les plus de 7 ans
1000 communistes qui sont propriétaires
c'est pourquoi il est très difficile
pour ceux qui veulent essayer deux
aimants jeudi à le bousculer les
cabistes n'ont pas nos propres
pas un mot sur les militants qui fondent
comme neige au soleil pas un mot non
plus sur une direction incapable de
retenir ses électeurs mais art au
capitalisme et éloge du socialisme sous
toutes ses formes
cet après midi on a applaudi la
démocratisation des pays de l'est pour
mieux dénoncer les vues mercantile du
gouvernement français sur ces nouveaux
marchés au terme de ces trois jours
force est de constater qu'il n'y a rien
de nouveau en fer communiste français le
vent de liberté qui souffle à lettres
n'a pas encore atteint la place du
colonel fabien
ici le vent est tellement chargé de
pluie au chili résultats officiels le
candidat de l'opposition patricio aylwin
a obtenu 50 5,2 pour cent des voix au
premier tour de scrutin vote massif
monsieur aylwin succédera en mars
prochain en général pinochet qui reste
chef de l'armée quelques incidents après
les élections bernard benyamin pascal c
est l etat lendemain de vote
peut être était ce ce soleil voilé qui
éclairait la ville ce matin
ou alors le travail qui offrit comme
auparavant
ou encore la fatigue accumulée au cours
de la campagne électorale
peut être était ce tout cela à la fois
mais santiago aujourd'hui semblait
désenchanté c'était particulièrement le
cas à l'évêché où se retrouvent toutes
les organisations des droits de l'homme
on était un peu déçu des résultats la
chambre de députés et au sénat la droite
conserve la majorité absolue ces
résultats nous force à continuer notre
lutte pour que le chili ne connaissent
plus jamais la dictature et ce qui s'est
passé durant ses 16 ans une profession
de foi mise en application quelques
minutes plus tard devant la prison de
santiago
ils sont une cinquantaine à réclamer la
liberté pour tous les prisonniers
politiques
et si les chiliens se posait encore des
questions sur le maintien de l'appareil
répressif il n'allait pas tarder à être
fixé
un peu plus loin dans les faubourgs de
la capitale
on a repris la grève oublier le temps
d'une journée de vote
c'est le deuxième problème que devra
affronter le nouveau gouvernement de
patricio aylwin répondre à l'immense
espoir des plus défavorisés d'une façon
ou d'une autre pour calmer les
travailleurs il faudra bien que le
gouvernement annonce des mesures
concrètes dans les 45 premiers jours
suivant son investiture
et puis par dessus tout ça il ya le cas
pinochet
selon la constitution il reste
commandant en chef des forces armées
garant de tout l'appareil militaire
qu'il a lui-même mis en place durant 16
ans autant dire que les mois qui
viennent seront difficiles pour le chili
si la dictature et bien terminé ce n'est
pas encore tout à fait la démocratie
voyons maintenant d'autres informations
essentiellement française ce soir c'est
louis carzou qui les commentent 6e
journée annuelle du comité national
d'éthique les sages favorables au don
d'embryon dans un cadre législatif
ces dons seraient au moins assortie de
deux conditions intangible la non
commercialisation des embryons et
l'anonymat les couples d'honneur
lancement aujourd'hui par le rpr de la
pétition nationale pour demander
l'organisation d'un référendum sur le
droit de vote des étrangers
alain juppé a annoncé la diffusion d'un
document de quatre pages à plusieurs
millions d'exemplaires
la question à poser selon le rpr serait
pour voter il faut être français
oui ou non
réunion à paris des douze ministres
européens de la justice ou de
l'intérieur les problèmes d'immigration
clandestine au centre des débats
les états membres de la communauté
européenne ont notamment envisagé la
mise en place n'a visa commun valable
pour les 12 pays
les ministres se sont également efforcés
d'harmoniser les droits et critères des
demandes d'asile
la bourse de paris a marqué une pause
aujourd'hui après les fortes pertes de
la semaine et du haut rhône ou
monétaires la séance s'est achevée sur
une légère baisse de 0,25 pour cent
même pose pour la devise américaine a
changé par rapport à hier à 5,5 le
football les clubs français plutôt gâtés
en coupe d'europe le tirage au sort des
quarts de finale avait lieu à zurich en
c1 marseille se reposer aux bulgares de
sofia en c2 monaco trouvera sur sa route
le real de valladolid les espagnols les
deux clubs adversaires des français sont
largement à la portée de ceux ci en c3
un peu plus difficile pour auxerre ce
sera les italiens de la fiorentina qui
déjà avait battu sochaux au tour
précédent
en tennis le premier point pour la suède
en finale de la coupe davis
mats wilander a battu l'allemand steib
mais ce fut dur jean ma mère karlovic
tuv a bien failli une nouvelle fois être
le héros de la coupe davis en un peu
plus de quatre heures il a poussé mats
wilander au plus profond de ses
retranchements
un match indécis de bout en bout
wilander pas au mieux de sa forme ne
parvient pas à faire la différence
ce thème accrocheur se bat sur tous les
points
chacun a commis son lot d'erreurs
villendeuil qu'elle refasse pour laisser
entièrement vide
quelques minutes plus tard je t'aide ne
passe pas cette volée qui pourtant le
remet dans le match
les occasions perdues ne se comptent
plus steve parvient bien à sauver une
première balle de match sur un
extraordinaire passings croisés de
revers en coupe davis le moral joue pour
beaucoup mais il ne fait pas tout
je t'ai ne peut rien sur un deuxième
balle de match et ils s'inclinent en
cinq sets après avoir fait trembler mats
wilander
cet après midi la suède a marqué son
premier point face à l'allemagne
et c'est la seule chose qui compte
kassav au zénith à paris c'est très
chaud depuis hier soir et c'est jusqu'à
noël c'est le déferlement des musiciens
antillais après le succès de la
compagnie créole qui a fait un tabac ces
jours derniers à l'olympia kassav donc
kassav c'est un succès international en
afrique en europe et à paris bien sûr
gérard dalmaz a rencontré ce groupe
black
fièvre au zénith avec le zouk cette
fameuse musique antillaise et l'un de
ses pionniers jacob desvarieux
c'est une surprise party ces gens le
titre lettre effet le week-end chez nous
au je
il ya une époque
des zooms avec 1300 casseurs on appelait
musique ska à présent vous ne savez pas
encore danser le zouk et bien cours
élémentaire première année ça se danse
comme ça et sa puce comme ça
antillais européens africains sont de
plus en plus nombreux à se retrouver
dans le zouk
parce que la culture des caraïbes c'est
un carrefour des influences un métissage
des racines une synthèse
on a reçu plein plein de choses qu'on
ait ces petits des choses qui étaient
peut-être amené obligatoirement chez
nous mais des choses qu'on a reçu tout
petit donc on a vraiment vécu comme si
c'était à nous
cantenac à cette idée
le zouk c'est une musique de l'avenir
selon miles davis zouk la sé sèl
médikaman nou ni entendez c'est le
remède contre la morosité de la vie bref
l'été en hiver
tiercé quarté + à vincennes demain voici
les pronostics de pierrette brès le 11
le 17 le 14 le 18 le neuf le 3 le 16 et
le 8
voilà laurent cabrol dans quelques
minutes pour une météo qui va décoiffer
ce week end
attention au vent dernière édition du
journal henri sannier vers 23 heures
juste après apostrophe présenté par
bernard pivot
comme chaque vendredi et puis pour le
week-end et bien daniel bilalian à 13
heures et à 20 heures à lundi bonne
soirée sur antenne 2